new yorks gouverneur andrew cuomo hofft
auf eine mögliche entspannung der lage
zwar sei die zahl der in der pandemie
gestorbenen menschen im vergleich zum
vortag um mehr als 600 tote gestiegen
diese zahl liegt aber so schlimm sie
auch ist im bereich der vergangenen tage
zudem sei die zahl der neu in
krankenhäuser aufgenommen patienten
deutlich zurückgegangen herbert
bauernebel berichtet für uns aus new
york in new york city sinniert
vielleicht die kritischen tage während
der ganzen krise angebrochen es wird
erwartet dass der höhepunkt bei den
infektionszahlen und bei den todesraten
erreicht wird möglicherweise am
donnerstag hier wird nun alles
mobilisiert in der stadt alles was new
york selbst zu bieten hat und auch alle
hilfestellungen werden angenommen die us
präsidenten donald trump hat jetzt 1000
militär mediziner in den big apple
entsandt auch das lazarettschiff der
nebel die us ns komforth soll nun
aufgrund einer entscheidung von donald
trump auch in der lage sein
carola patienten zu behandeln hier hat
es ein tauziehen gegeben und auch
bürokratische hürden bisher wurden nur
wenige patienten auf diesem einst mit
jubel empfangen im schiff behandelt auch
das service center das große messe
zentrum der stadt wurde bereits
ausgebaut eigentlich zum grössten spital
americas mit 2500 betten all das ist
sehr gut angekommen beim gouverneur des
staates andrew cuomo der gesagt hat wir
haben jetzt kapazitäten um
möglicherweise diese krise bewältigen zu
können natürlich die lage in den
spitälern ist nach wie vor sehr knapp am
limit
es reicht wahrscheinlich die mittel nur
mehr für wenige tage aus dann muss es
neun nachschub geben es gibt dramatische
szenen
einige spitälern in brooklyn wo auch
todesfälle verzeichnet werden unter dem
personal auch ärzte sind hier ums leben
gekommen nach infektionen das natürlich
führt zu weiteren schockierenden
zuständen hier in new york auf ein
vorschlag eines lokal abgeordneten hat
hier in new york für aufsehen gesorgt
ein mann namens mark levin ein mitglied
das city council hat allen ernstes
vorgeschlagenes würde pläne geben dass
man die toten in massengräbern in new
yorker parks beerdigt und zwar in
ausgehobene gräben mit bis zu zehn
leichen nebeneinander in holzsärgen
gelegt
das ganze wurde natürlich von den
offiziellen sofort verworfen
der gouverneur in giacomo sagte über
diesen plan habe er noch nie etwas
gehört also entscheidende stunden dort
in new york fielen dank herbert
bauernebel